Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm ready to dream about this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a toasted or untoasted I can live my
toast to the lovers and so see you doing
night do you
good morning Millennials happy Friday
happy merch day it's Mercia we've never
had a merchant and a Friday and another
loving it
no we usually do like actually there's
no rhyme or reason but it's definitely
never been a better day that is our
brand messaging no rhyme or reason right
but here we are and I'm loving merch on
a Friday because it makes this Friday
even sweeter it's payday and it's just
gonna be a great Mirchi day no I
definitely woke up today even though I
did wake up with anal leakage I woke up
also with that Kinect sure bouncing my
spirit yeah because it's merch day it's
Friday my Chicago tickets go on sale at
11 a.m. Central Time 29 minutes and it's
just like it's a good day to be nicer
for sure also we're matching again on an
accident I wore this last night to joke
don't judge me okay so these are our new
TMT bombers are the most expensive item
that we've ever sold yeah and that are
in this job but and how much are they I
believe locally I'll just check I just
check in the meantime I'll model then so
okay I guess we decided who's the model
in this girl
it says tow stern on the left breast in
cursive and then and so it's like low
key from the front and then it's a party
in the back what size are you wearing
I'm wearing a cyi
I'm wearing a size large but to be
honest I might order another extra-large
cuz I like when a bomber layovers my
titties I would go for another large and
then this is something I'd be great at a
festival I'm just gonna model it for one
second and I will oh and here we have
Jackie looking like a big [ __ ] taking
her arms out and that's not something
all of us can do so it must be nice
people like to have their arms Haley
Bieber she actually started it before
well I just called her Haley Bieber like
for no rhyme or reason this is my fave I
know I've been saying that about every
item but this is my favorite item I'm
always looking for a jacket like this
for concerts
someone get higher than my weight this
is a concert jacket for sure for sure so
it has like a nice wind breaking
material
she'll definitely be breaking wind when
you air it that's that's all one can ask
for from a windbreaker this is our most
expensive item it's $60 so I think we're
we're pretty good on the price front
like nothing is well is above $60 on the
hats are $35 sorority sweatshirts range
from 40 to 55 the crop hoodie which is
gonna be everyone's favorite are 50
t-shirts 30 to 35 dollars pop sockets we
got four for $8 bargain koozies $8
stickers 10 to $15 pencil cases $15
folders $15 journals $30 it's all under
$60 shot Maureen chose comm site will be
live as the show ads but we have time
for my Scott on today so you're in
buckle up it's gonna be a wild ride wild
Disgrace Queens too tired by your wires
what was her name who wrote that article
Sara inspired by Saren Sara I would say
her last name at the New York Post thank
you for making us some money Queen you
are a disgrace Queen Sara yeah it's
Queen thank you for writing that
beautiful article about me
borderline defamatory yeah but now
you're gonna make money off of it so
thank you so much you know it's so
appreciated you'll never know what
you've done for our business that's
always what happens like people like
come for us and then they end up
changing our business in the most
positive way right and I like every time
I like someone comes for me in the news
like I always got a pit in my stomach
but in my in my heart of hearts I know
that like there's a reason for it
yeah I feel like every time we've ever
been dragged through the news like our
company and our brand benefits even more
it just gets stronger stronger better
bigger I love it so it's an exciting
time merch is available so you know I'm
obsessed with this drop and I have
everything and I've been using
everything and I'm excited for everyone
to get when I got every single item I
laid it out on my dining room table and
it's still sitting there and every time
I just like wake up and like what should
I wear today and like do I need to you
know take any journals totally you need
to start journaling I definitely think
that these types of journals really will
bring out like a more emotion emotive
and more sensitive side of me oh I
wanted to share a personal anecdote
because I went out last night to a
friend's birthday party and I went to
dinner and you know who I ran into at
dinner and actually got to meet the
toasters are gonna die Tyler say
well I already knew this so he was so
handsome such a nice guy Barry
you know like humble you know like you
would have thought nothing of him if he
didn't watch a bow sure because he's
just like a regular guy in a restaurant
like he doesn't you know some of those
bachelor guys with their slicked back
hair like they walk into a restaurant
they're gone from the batch give me a
table you know ya know he was just very
weird you go to dinner
polo bar okay that's what I thought
which is slowly turning into my favorite
restaurant in the city it's a good one
maybe I should be my birthday there Oh
want that but literally booked
reservation now ya know it is the best
restaurant the best food the best vibe
and there's always guaranteed to see a
famous person so for other people I
guess the famous person was me and for
me I got to see Tyler saying it was
really special you had to see Tyler
let's see I put the seat in Tyler see he
was a medic you date and like you tell
these big shoulders and Ben was there
too and Ben was like who was that guy
I'm like Oh Scott Tyler take it what
does he - his hands are [ __ ] huge
like he's just how he's a contractor
right and he was a football player he
was yeah I saw that somewhere and I read
it for the first time he did a GQ thing
did you say and they referred to him as
an ex-football player interesting we
should ask the snatchler but she's been
snatched because I'm sure Cameron Boyce
Codd is arriving also I need to talk to
the senator about meeting me Elaine
Martin went to an event last I wish she
had to meet me Elaine anyone else like
so shook by those photos and videos Neil
Lane is kind of like this ethereal
figure like I've known who Neil Lane is
pretty much my whole life and he's been
a part of my life in terms of the
bachelor franchise but also just being
like a business owner and you just don't
ever expect to meet those kinds of
people that would be that meaning Jared
yeah I'm Jarrett hey from Kay Jewelers
right Pandora Mike Vanderpump yeah
totally
well it's gonna be a great show we have
some great stories it's Friday like just
the vibes are great vibes really are
great except for the diarrhea that I had
this morning that I know I keep talking
about in this like really disgusting I
really am sorry um I think it's shaping
up to be quite a delicious Friday
diarrhea is such a gift it is a gift
it's just it's really more based on a
time and place thing like you've been a
gift on the subway no but you were in
your house give it I was demolished at
home I was rush it's it's not a gift
when you have 20 minutes to get ready
you're already running so late and you
like it the beat drops for the diarrhea
well you know the middle of putting on
concealer so I had to blend out the
concealer and put baking powder on
before I got about on the toilet because
I'm not gonna what have a creased
situation
yeah but it would be good to like bake
your face on the toilet what I did very
smart multi hat and Pia was just like
staring at me the whole time like I
could I think he could tell I was like
in a lot of pain oh my god how is he he
is so like honestly I'm gonna say this
every time but last night me and Ben got
home at like 1 o'clock and he had had a
walk with his Walker who's like his best
friend and it was raining and so when I
got back he was like covered in mud so I
like 1:00 in the morning I got the tub
with Fiona like we just took a bath
together and honestly it was like it was
like so good like it was just amazing
like and then he was all dry and smelled
so bad and like we laid in my bed and
just like we're happy you know mm-hmm
that feeling of happiness is one in
which you can't buy no you can actually
you can if you buy the morning shows
March yeah it's keeping me real happy
yeah not to get emotional sorry ok well
we got to be gay in front of us so I
think it's time yep to deliver the past
5 stories that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and I want to talk about
today's sponsor because I saw a
commercial for new last night on TV and
I was so moved by it like they had a
great song and a great message and I was
like I know them you know I felt really
proud to be a partner totally because
getting in shape isn't just about losing
weight it's about learning healthier
habits and feeling better about yourself
whether that's more stamina to keep up
with your busy life finally getting into
those gold jeans or being more in tune
with your body's needs or practicing
self-care so basically um Noom is this
online um it's a habit changing solution
that helps users learn to develop new
relationships with food through
personalized courses it's based in
psychology it's not a diet it's healthy
and in an easy to stick to a way of life
it's based on cognitive behavioural
approach we just say it works you guys
um it's easy and convenient um because
of their app it's basically a little bit
like the community of the morning
toasters it's like supportive and there
for you and you just open up your phone
you think you know what are the toasters
gonna help me with today you open the
phone and be like how's noon gonna
change my life today no food is
considered good bad or off-limits they
teach moderation and it can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want I think that's
the hardest part I struggle with losing
anyway because you're like okay lose you
mean I can't eat chocolate and then like
you eventually just have a mental
breakdown cuz you want to eat some
[ __ ] chocolate and it's Halloween and
they're starting to sell Halloween candy
no no mister
that like you can eat chocolate which is
like one yeah you know what wifey the
moderation why 30 you know 100 percent
you don't have to change it all in one
day it's small steps to making big
progress sign up for your child today at
noon calm / toast that's n oo m.com /
toast what do you have to lose
visit noon calm / chose to start your
trial today that's Noom dot-com / toast
the last weight loss program you'll ever
need
sign on look snatch what do you have to
lose actually like that um so again sign
on looks snatched like the snapshot
coming to you one day soon okay first
story a little confirmation from some
toaster originated news this week but
Miley Cyrus has been spotted kissing
Cody Simpson got more than just mates so
while we had the original story TMZ has
the video of them like kissing in some
sort of restaurant I don't know what
restaurant up backyard bowls eatery in
LA
yeah um and like the kissing is quite
strange did anyone watch it yes yes I
did it's like very tender very very
almost like maternal no stop okay fine
sorry it's just like no it's like TZ is
this isn't the first kiss oh I see your
son know what I mean this is like a yeah
it was very much like a peck no it was
like a a middle of their relationship
kiss well as much as I'm upset that the
toast isn't getting the proper credit
they deserve I'm really relieved at like
everyone who listens to this show is now
like a fully informed person you know it
looks like you could just be on TMZ and
like you already know stuff it's not
such a special feeling that's what it
being a toaster is yeah we have insider
information yeah and I'm glad that our
insider information actually turned out
to be true thank you it was the first
time we did a toast source yeah anyways
this is just now that it's totally
confirmed
this couple is extra strange because
like he's Australian much like Liam
Hemsworth oh it's just like that's crazy
maybe she just has a type blonde blonde
ah she no but I feel like Liam would be
pissed about this one yes younger Lea it
hits a little close to home literally I
mean but like he's know am I think he's
a Liam but like why he was my leaves
sleep over the opinion of Cody Simpson
you know but he's no but he has Miley
you know yeah but like Liam her now for
now yeah I think she's just in a fun
stage in her life where she was tied
down for so long and really as Miley
tried to tell us she can't be tamed so I
think she's just like bouncing back
having fun she was having a great time
yeah yeah like being single Miley sily
yeah this is just really great like I
kind of never predicted this I feel like
Cody Simpson is just so like such a boy
where does one even meet Cody Simpson
like does he go out he probably goes out
yeah just he live in a line yeah I think
so yeah we probably met it like a house
party no I'm sure they already knew each
other from that night but they probably
reunited at a house party
they probably reunited like she doesn't
want whiskey and pills she just wants
her house in the hills right right so
maybe they reunited house yeah I think
that that sounds right
what squiddy since in a Disney kid no he
believed Disney Jason yeah you know but
like they who plays music videos on on
yeah that's for sure he definitely had
some sort of record deal like with
Disney yeah like how the Jonas Brothers
had by the way when I was at dinner last
night I was also with Gregg Sulkin and I
always forgot that he was on Wizards of
Waverly Place like I wanted to ask him a
million questions you forget because
that was in like this new Marvel show so
that's like a big deal yeah and I just
looked like so many questions about like
Disney like culture you know did you ask
them you know I feel like people find
that annoying you know and I'm just
trying I'm just happy to be at these
places I'm not trying get kicked out you
know yeah I think you can ask I feel
like he's an open book he's actually
very cool I love him yeah and been like
what at first was not gonna let me come
to dinner because Greg and Ben tax and
they were like going to dinner I'm like
oh as Michelle they're I'll come to
dinner Michelle wasn't in town sometimes
like okay I will just go us too I'm like
excuse me no you will not
so I came and I invited everyone I know
I know he ends up and to being a great
time I'd love to hear it love to hear it
it's so hard to find a good time these
days Jackie you just said a mouthful
it's crazy it's borderline impossible
yeah and it's not only that it's like
there could be a good time but like your
mental state isn't there it is
impossible to find a good time that's
worth leaving your house for right and
like all the cars have to line up we're
like not too tired you're not too drunk
like it's just such a balancing the
balancing act of being tired and drunk
is one that I don't think science will
ever be able to discover okay
it's really torture like actually last
night I had I was on my second margarita
and I was like flying you know like when
you have your first drink of the day and
you're like yeah and then all of a
sudden I got so fatigued my back starts
hurting I guess anyway this is back
hurting in this chair they're like no
and it got so hot and like I really just
like had a I think the margarita was
really sugary and I wasn't like a sugar
high and then I just immediately crashed
like the night was pretty much ruined
and I was still at dinner
damn but why why does that happen I was
definitely the sugar yeah what'd you
think
uh-huh seeing is like a delicate art I
was um last night I went out with two
friends and I just had a glass of wine I
didn't even finish it and it just
totally turned my night upside down
really up until that point I was like
feeling great I did like this speaking
engagement at a PR place and so we went
to drinks after I had less than maybe
half the glass it destroyed my mood I
took everything I mean I went home I had
to like lay in bed like as if I was
going to sleep from like 7 o'clock to 9
o'clock then I was up until 2:00 what it
was awful
that's weird the wine doesn't do that
yeah it stripped me of every bit of
serotonin in my brain it was awful
into her song yeah so I think I just
stopped drinking wine I need more
serotonin
I mean rich by work we buy like a
shadowy to us I need a syringe and
there's one like inject it into my brain
they're doing happiness yeah oh my god I
would love some serotonin yeah there
should be a song about serotonin oh also
new dan and chase song released with
Justin Bieber called 10,000 hours
[ __ ] flat I enjoy it I listen to it
once I didn't like lisslow do about I'm
sure eventually it'll stick with me I
think I just have like an adverse
reaction to Justin Bieber singing voice
now like I don't really like his songs
oh you know what it's like as much as
everyone tries to hate Justin Bieber
time after time he releases Boehner
after me I like him but like his songs
and his voice like I just I don't want
to hear it anymore I don't mind it I
really like his songs except Esposito
that one we got played a little too much
and now I'm over it yeah it was going on
to snatch her she's like coughing and
honestly it's like you're her coffee
yeah just you know really sucky she's my
girl we could still hear you we can hear
you are you okay
okay are you okay you choking on
something what's going on
I was just something to say are you okay
I'll explain so I got up first because I
had to go get Cameron lista and then I
was having an itch in my throat and I
felt it off his hat coming on and I
tried to get rid of it with one cough
but then it continued and caught it gave
me a look so I walked out and I coughed
you guys have any memorable moments
where like you had a cough like at the
worst possible yes I do too I remember
once in college I got a popcorn kernel
stuck in my throat for like 24 hours and
I was just coffee I couldn't stop you
know I mean a lot especially like
embarrassing like I'll never forget when
I when we used to take piano lessons I
had a piano recital and I was actually
like for the first time we had we had
like two resettles every year for the
first time I was actually prepared and I
was really excited I was playing a piece
called Sophia toe and I sat down at the
piano and like I had a little coffin my
throat and I ignored it and I spent the
entire time playing the piece with this
cough like bulging out of my throat but
I knew that if I close my eyes and
coughed are like really like moves like
I would [ __ ] up the whole piece so I'm
like literally rushing through the
[ __ ] piece it was horrible I
shouldn't just caught in the beginning
yeah I look are you so weird I literally
have amnesia I don't remember anything
but I remember that that's crazy
yeah sorry about that says if it's worth
anything I don't remember it so okay
don't worry
no okay next story the saga of Travis
Scott and Kylie Jenner continues and now
there's a lot of different conspiracy
theories Travis Scott dropped a video
for highest in the room after Kylie
Jenner split lyrics say you say you love
me but she's mine right here we list a
song today yes Travis Scott has released
his highly anticipated track highest in
the room along with the music video
following his split from Kylie Jenner as
many fans know the track was first
teased in one of her promotional videos
for CAI browse the video for the music
video opens with Scott smoking while
standing underneath a cluster of storm
clouds lyrics go I got room in my fumes
she filled my mind with ideas I'm the
highest in the room then he says so the
song came about Kylie when I'm with you
I feel alive you say you love me don't
you I get the song was written a while
ago
it's not necessarily about kind of
breakup but now there's all this stuff
you saw like the mistress oh my god the
mistress in the circus [ __ ] I've ever
met in my life
her Instagram page is like going private
in five minutes you better follow it
like she's insane if anyone cannot see
through the thirst of this this side
chick whatever you want to call her then
I can't even talk to you
I totally by the way a legendary cough
was gonna choked oh of course of course
um this mistress business I'm not buying
it but now people are saying that the
breakup is just a decoy because she's
pregnant again right and that I saw in
the toasters and the toasters had some
concrete evidence that she was at
cedars-sinai and the maternity wing the
other day I just I refused to believe
that she would be that like lazy and not
have a private at-home thing yeah and we
remember the girl who started the rumor
that she's in labor when she was in yeah
that was a big fat lie and they actually
ended up in the Daily Mail yeah and then
we interviewed her on our Super Bowl
show we interviewed - the girl who made
up the lie we did yeah in that epic
Super Bowl show where we were doing a
live show and Josh from Josh Altman
assisted take a photo of him we're like
literally on the slide shame with our
microphones with our Bing career look we
had a legit setup and Josh oh man he has
an interview us we asked him to
interview he was a guest shortly Jake
show me first and we were like sure we
did it
funniest thing ever anyways I'm pretty
sure we interviewed that girl um so
there's a lot of lies floating around
I'm not believing anything for now
because I'm just believing in in piling
yeah no and to be honest like sad
sometimes like music is just music you
know what I mean
yeah like people write songs with other
song songwriters like that's kind of
what I learned from song land like the
way they tap into like real life
experiences but not like so literally
they're like you know that feeling like
when someone doesn't love you back like
he's not talking about a specific person
you're just talking about the feeling in
general so I think that sometimes it's
okay for a song to just be a song and
not need like a breakdown but unless
it's a Taylor Swift song song unless
it's like slide away by Miley Cyrus
right or like thank you next I are and
we're so obvious I thought I'd end up
with Sean but it wasn't a match I even
almost got married at for Pete I'm so
thankful I think that's about Pete
Davidson it's hard to know who she's
talking there's so many Pete's you know
yeah so I think these lyrics don't like
shock me in a way that I think they're
worth decoding I think it might just be
like a banger you know yeah and and it's
a
to leave it at that I agree and I just I
think everyone's making this much more
than it is me to just because of the
timing of it all
yeah and because that's what we do as a
society oh I see your next story and I'm
very much interested
Colten Underwood inserts himself into
Rachel Lindsay and Raven Gates's feud
okay so [ __ ] kidding like Raven and
Rachel's food is making the rounds
because Rachel didn't watch repens live
which by the way I cannot believe she
did watch trapline 3 Bachelor people in
one week after not having after only
having one person in the last 10 there
was a policy change something's going on
something's going on and I'm so here for
it and the people that they're deciding
to put as bartenders and the people
they're deciding to put as guess is
premium Rachel watches every franchise
they played a game like she killed it
and then someone called in and was like
please tell us what happened between you
and Raven and she was like honestly like
I promised her that I would never
because I think it's like so tacky and
shady but just it was enough for me to
never be her friend again and I will
never be her friend again that's what
she said
right so someone post on Instagram like
about the feud and Colton it was
immediately like wrote a thirsty article
Colton comment table success Weekly did
credit us are the originators of this
story like we give tabloids a bad name
on this show but I have to say
Us Weekly is time and time after anytime
they report something and the person has
been on the toast they have like link
back to that rating gates on the toast
like 1,000 times they give credit where
credit's due and we appreciate you
adding factor Rachel on the to us for
sweet we originally had this
conversation like this wasn't new news
to us what's new news is Colton
inserting himself saying shocker
Rachel mad at another person does she
like anyone what's his beef with Rachel
Rachel how do they even know each other
can we connect um well they definitely
have met through bachelor things and
remember the Winter Games but so very
Colton at the Winter Games
no that was very wait so Rachel season
who him the bachelor Ari no Rachel
season who became a minute
no no cuz remember everyone right here
alright yeah re and then Ari was who
Becca who friend Colton yes oh there's
so many like there's no real connection
I don't even know what kind of beef they
could possibly have yeah I guess that
they do has Beast I'm sorry like making
a fight on Instagram comments is like
the thirstiest move yeah and when you're
like a bachelor
like you should stay above yeah I
actually completely agree like once
you've gotten that paycheck for being a
full-time lead bachelor/bachelorette
like you were on a different level when
you're in you're still in a relationship
like it's yeah you have to stay above
the [ __ ] and there has to be like
respect between the leaves I agree or
else it just doesn't work I agree it's a
very delicate hierarchy Oh so speaking
of Colton he obviously doesn't watch a
show because he hasn't stopped I'm doing
cheesy and sir grams of anything like
they've been doubling down yeah and it's
out of control it's out of control and I
only like I don't I'm not one of those
people who like analyzes Instagram
couples relationships like I'm in the
blog toast and tea group and they're
obsessed with like people's marriage
isn't like and like the inauthenticity
and I don't really care look if you want
to be fake on Instagram like sure I'm
fake too like I put up pictures when me
and Ben are fighting like whatever but
there's something here that's so
inherently obviously cheesy that it's
making me question look and I'm not one
to to make grand
grandiose assumptions based off of
people's Instagram activity but there's
something going on because it's
incredibly weird it's not sure what do
you think they're doubling down on the
cheesy posts it's it's I mean maybe they
just want to prove us wrong I don't know
like they listen to the toasts and they
think that we think it's cheesy and then
they're like oh well make it even
cheesier you don't even know cheesy yeah
okay
um in the comments people are breaking
it down for us Colton said that he had
never met Rachel but Rachel was trashing
him - Cassie how does Cassie even know
Rachel David from the podcast but like I
think they met at an event I mean I know
everyone knows everyone but this seems
like a really like rubber rachel is
bridge along another stratosphere like
she hosts his show on MTV like she got
on watch happens I've like I'm sounding
me ESPN like I wish people would stop
asking about the Raymond drama cause
like it's whatever like it's a
friendship like let let them handle it
like she's just like she's another level
yeah it's reaching I'm it's ricci vibes
at best and I hope Rachel doesn't
respond she's so much better than this
behind your princess I'm gonna see her
attacks me like I'll respond that's a
good idea
I love like um you know manipulating pop
culture next story is a little it
business which is person to the
situation because we have some business
themed items dropping today morning shop
morning toaster pencil cases pens
pencils notebooks folders journals uber
launches an app to connect jogs to
connect job seekers with gig work what
the company is launching uber works app
on Thursday in Chicago in an effort to
make it easier to find temporary shifts
for work like bartending warehouse work
and commercial cleaning it's said in a
blog post it's actually so smart it will
connect gig workers with employers
looking for temporary status right so
it's like a dating app almost for it's a
jobs and and especially if you drive
uber they only let you work so many hour
in every city it's different but they
only let you work so many hours a day in
days a week so you have time to pick up
other ships but not like a full-time job
and there's so many industries where
like your job is just like a shifty
airship they're so smart so smart
they said we believe a new technology
first approach can provide faster and
easier means for people to get to work
while offering greater insight into many
opportunities for work that are out
there improving the experience for
workers and businesses alike I think
this is like a great move on Uber's part
like you know for the world and also for
them because they're struggling like
with perception right just like every
time I hear about uber the news I'm like
oh no how much money are they losing
today right
what is with uber being one of the
biggest companies in the world and
literally have no has never made the
dollar no and like everyone hating them
and yet we use them every day yeah I'm
not sure but they're making strides to
to correct these wrongs I think this is
a really good idea I think so too
I'm actually excited about it like in
certain cities I can really see it being
I could see it being huge in LA because
so many people are like aspiring actors
and they just have certain jobs to pay
the bills whereas like acting is really
their passion so they could just pick up
a couple shifts you know that works from
their audition schedule then Joey
Tribbiani
you know it's launching in Chicago
hopefully it goes well there so it'll
span to other cities because me job four
minutes four minutes till my tickets
December 9 xx and 21st
tickets available at the Vic theater
check it out very exciting stuff and
move fast I would suggest this and final
story we just breezed right through that
we breezed right through it I just like
it's hard to take long with the stories
and we have like premium merch
right
to that I know ready to ship but fifth
and final story Instagram launches
threads a close friend chat app with
Auto status so this is interesting
what if Instagram could automatically
tell your close friends your home
working on the move or chilling and that
you might want to hang out do you tell
people and your friends know you know
hosts friends list
I still lie to my a lie to you guys but
I don't want to hang out don't see
Melanie tell my close friends like she
doesn't know when I'm coming home that's
a new idea behind instagrams new
companion app threads a close friends
only messaging experience that opens to
the camera with shortcuts for instantly
sending specific people photos and
videos so it's more snap to ask with a
little bit of find my friends threads
offers toon brand new features called
status and auto status that allow you to
manually set an emoji as an away message
to show close friends what you're up to
or opt into letting instagrams select
one automatically based on your location
how terrifying a or based on your
accelerometer or even your phone's
battery level no no no no I'm not only
happy with the state of Instagram right
now like and they released so many
changes over the last year like we just
take a break like I say out of my stay
out of might this is just there's
co-opting snapchat more and they want to
be more for like kids you know yeah
messaging one-to-one which is smart they
just want to like capture more where
these are more audience are GU still you
snapchat you're like our guinea pig here
I do but like I don't story but like I
mean my friend snapchat each other wait
and I guess they're seeing like that
being a huge trend for users like nobody
really uses stories anymore they just do
it to extend ugly selfies like yeah yes
yeah yeah yeah and use it to snapchat
your camper yeah right so I technically
you soundtrack every day multiple times
yes but I think you guys have like this
little relationship on snapchat one in
which like mean Olivia are not part of
its really likes you get the campers
messages no I don't have snapchat I
delete it a long time so then you can't
be upset about something you can't
participate in yeah can't lose something
you never had yeah and the campers
honestly like they're just needing to be
counseled at all times
sorry true it's crazy yeah so Instagram
like try as you may you already ruined
snapchat like talk about beating a dead
horse you know I don't know every time
they've stolen someone's idea like it
goes pretty well for them
always also stories is a it's working
out fabulously it's fabulously Instagram
live
cetera um and I feel as though close
friends is something that people really
like and they are wanting to expand on
and I rarely use my close friends and my
clothes it's weird because my close
friends are just like you guys I know a
friends who don't barely use Instagram
maybe like we well I can't relate to
this like new outtake cuz I literally
have no friends
like it's just you it would be you guys
yeah I just think younger people's
social media behavior is different than
ours so we can't relate yeah it's
actually so crazy like how we're all
human but we're different species ya
know ya know just our behaviors okay
um stuff okay should we bring out
Cameron Wescott wow that was like so
brief I know
well it's 11 o'clock we're going to take
a two-minute break go get cameron
Wescott if you want to take a quick
break go get your tickets to my Chicago
show we'll be back in like two to three
minutes if you have any questions for
Cameron wife Scott feel free to drop
them in the YouTube feed or on our
Instagram post if Cameron we will do our
absolute best to get them all to you get
a snack take a break go to the bathroom
targets alley at the water cooler we'll
see you in a minute
you
with the queen of Dallas Cameron
Westcott the queen of Highland Park
actually we took a trip because Jackie's
in-laws live in Dallas and we went to
Highland Park I'm going to hide the park
village I mean really felt like it we
had the most radical time that Boyard
store it's amazing
I like Larry's my favorite place I
because also you can park right in front
the store yes which is like right there
yeah it's a bit yeah you have to come
the lights yes oh my god I'm sorry yeah
is there over the holidays it's so nice
it's like Paul Marc yeah we want to move
to Highland Park oh yeah but when you
know the same guy who designed Beverly
Hills actually designed Highland Park
Billy oh yes and that amazing that's
amazing looks like almost identical to
Beverly Hills oh oh you know that
actually makes a lot of sense so
interesting well you are here your
second season of Real Housewives of
Dallas
may I just say the growth yeah how is
times we just met you I know I know I I
agree
well then that actually makes more sense
because you have really like developed
as a character so much and I'm gonna be
coming on this show at a better times
like we showed was so Hortis so so I
didn't realize like what this franchise
was missing was the friendship between
you and Brandi because the most unlikely
of friends but it actually makes a lot
of sense when you think about and please
I was like if she comes here and tells
me that now they're not friends like I'm
gonna be so upset
Oh what is the status we are praying to
God yes we are
I mean I actually yeah text her like two
days ago yeah yeah I I love Brandi I
really do she's such a good person has
such an amazing heart I mean I honestly
think we just got off on the wrong foot
big time and I feel like when you don't
know someone you could automatically
stereotype each other for yeah I'm
thingy and and I feel like once we get
to know each other and she knew that I
was fun like I you did a flower no and
it's like my other friend groups you
could ask them they're like Cameron is
so fun but you know when you're new to a
group yeah like it's hard yeah it's
hardly the game
you're fun like you just need to spend
did you feel like Kari introduced you as
as that stereotype maybe I mean I really
don't know what it was I think it was
just so guarded going in to hanging out
with these women that you know the first
impressions they got they just
automatically judge me by my zip code
yeah yeah automatically I think if you
were like we did - yeah I didn't realize
it until this week when you said to
Stephanie like I've always been this
person you guys have just refused to see
it and I was like no you're talking to
me like yeah you're right and it was
heartbreaking to me because being a
newbie into the group look I really it
was hard for me because I never felt
accepted yeah I know that's like crazy
hear that but that's the honest truth
yeah I didn't feel accepted I just felt
like no one really wanted to get to know
me because they just figured oh you're
just one of those people yeah you know
so after the first season and the second
season do you ever feel like not coming
back like this isn't worth it like this
isn't worth putting my life out there
for people not even to exciting this
year I actually had so much fun and
actually it was really fun cuz I'm
really building strong relationships
with music and I do feel that like
because of that I joined out with that
yeah like I want to hang out and it just
happens to me that there's a camera
right ya know like it's a true friend
group but I feel like those that's the
best type of show it's like you can
always tell when they start filming like
they haven't seen each other since the
reunion that's the worst you know yes
and I definitely feel real friendships
developing um let's talk about new
Carrie it's kind of crazy that we lost
Carrie and got a Carrie
um you couldn't have planned it better
what are you are you guys close what is
I'm obsessed with her eventually the
closest to her right now with all the
other women I'm closer than Leanne uh
actually right now yes you can question
I think that you and Leanne's friendship
is an anomaly and yeah I mean and I
don't understand it but whatever it's
not my business but she's you and Brandi
really got off on the wrong foot do you
feel like you two might have been able
to make it work better and faster if
Leigh Ann wasn't inserting herself you
know no because this thing when I first
met LeAnn I was so afraid of her okay
because of slavery things
I was like petrified of her but you know
I I knew going into the experience I
wanted to not judge anyone I wanted to
you know accept everyone for who they
were and really try to get to know
people and I thought this is so crazy
you're not gonna believe this but Leanne
was the first one I felt like that
didn't have any judgments against me
and you actually yeah yeah yeah she
accepted me for who I was
yeah and just you know she's
non-judgmental and just took me in and
swept me off my feet and we just hit it
off and I think because of that is why
her and I got so close and then people
now just think sometimes I'm her pet or
whatever but you know but you're just
like whale friends and just oh well I'm
a loyal but I also stick up to her yeah
some people don't think I do because
sometimes I agree with her yeah and then
it looks like with tea Mina right and
we're like trying to like protect each
other but it's really just that I agreed
with her in certain situation yeah yeah
are you still making pink dog food yes I
am actually but I'm on a halt right now
because I'm waiting for my new recipe to
be perfected well but right now in the
market I have my chewy multivitamin
heart-shaped treats queue and they're
actually they're not really traced but
they're multivitamins even the dogs
think their traits Oh smart and I also
have my sparkle dog shampoo on Amazon as
well what oh my gosh you guys it you
know it obviously has some sparkles but
it doesn't make them Sparkle yet but I'm
trying to develop a product that will
make them Sparkle Wow shiny coat yeah I
want to take some questions from
Instagram because we got so many for you
oh this is a good question cuz I know a
lot of your friends watch your toes
yeah would you consider yourself more a
Claudia or a Jackie you know it's so I'm
making you more of a Jackie okay I love
that I love that I actually feel like
I'm kind of both the same time that's
what I don't know the best combination
yeah sometimes I'm glad you two though
yeah when you're drunk you're Claudia
cuz Claudia is always drunk
someone it's a good question about the
process I'm filming with your
mother-in-law yeah did you have to
convince her a lot oh yeah you know
originally she'd not want me do the show
well you know very protective and she
just don't want me to get hurt she's
just like a mama bear yeah I get it you
know but now she's we're willing to film
with me once in a while just to support
me that's really nice
your husband likes you being on the show
you know at first he was not for it that
happens I feel awkward at all but now I
have to be honest like he's okay with
the whole thing he's okay because he
knows I could protect myself yeah he
knows I'm gonna stand my ground and he
also knows I'm not gonna you know go
below the belt and hurt people you know
he knows that yeah at least not
intentionally and what about the kids
do they like be on camera they do as
long as it's on their terms
that's what Stephanie said yeah if it's
not nursers and I was given the option
yeah they don't want to film they could
go on upstairs and do their own thing I
never want a foursome
but usually they come around yeah it has
to be fun like me this is a great
question we got for you from Sydney
Novick how was your commercial flight to
Mexico
okay it was great obviously you know I
played commercial all the time as well
it's so funny you know just because our
family has a private plane I mean people
think that that's all I fly right I mean
but little did they know like we flew
you're in commercial I'm young you know
it just depends where we're going and if
we're worth the whole family yeah we'll
go on the the private Lea but you know
obviously it usually goes with my
father-in-law wherever he goes you know
that's his and if we're lucky to get on
it we're lucky I got it oh so Stephanie
was here last week and she told us that
you used that restroom on the way to I
couldn't believe I say there's no way I
cannot use that toilet you guys it was
scary and I just knew don't touch
anything you squat it your touch yeah oh
I always squat I squat everywhere I go
you guys yeah I think that's how you
have such more beautiful legs oh yeah
yeah yeah I was blessed I was blessed I
could squat I can now believe okay do
you ever plan to learn Spanish oh my
gosh I wish Spanish I wish I you know I
took Spanish literally so many years and
I can't it just I make a fool myself
sound ridiculous it just doesn't flow I
can't roll my tongue yeah that's so I
just sounds so ridiculous
my daughter he'll know oh she rolls her
tongue my god it's like when they were
at a young age like they're gonna be so
fluent yes hoping you're easy to you
know and that's why I just keep I keep
on with the Spanish lessons yeah it's
really smart have you ever heard of
Sharpay Evans from
School Musical oh my god I wish you are
like the grown-up version of sharp and
she's fabulous and honestly like people
thought she was not me but she was
actually a very talented good person and
it hit me hard to really relate to her
yes I love it we see a question from
Carmen Arabia who is your style icon
oh great style you are so sweet okay
you're gonna laugh but I love ok ladies
of London I love Juliet oh I love
Caroline Stanbury face dad yeah lunch
ever
I mean and they're not even like you
know these huge slabs like but it's like
they're celebs and it's like I'm
obsessed yeah
what they wear I'm like oh my gosh I'll
buy everything jewelry that has a great
Instagram yeah yeah yeah she has great
clothes it's actually a really good
that's the answer yeah um are there any
other housewives in the national
franchise that you're close with words
well I do love teddy you know I see
daddy every once why when I go to LA I
love her I feel like she's just so real
done
she's the nicest girl and I love meeting
all the housewives have Andy shower I'm
obsessed I got Ellis about that uh they
were oh you like that was like in my
bucket list I was like a train yeah it
was the biggest superfan for this show
and somehow I ended up on the show it's
a dream why do you have a dream no I
like it so I'm like when I see other
housewives I'm like yeah but yeah I'm
like the superfan and I feel like
awkward sometimes because you know they
probably think I'm crazy but know any of
your little dream for anything
how's my okay I love the New Jersey
girls okay I well I'm up all the
franchise's obviously but I am obsessed
with Jackie I love Jackie obviously and
then Jennifer yeah yeah babe I said were
so sweet they get on the show together
and I I think they were really not
getting along at the time and it was
really awkward and interesting like
because actually I think Jennifer came
off work yes she's pretty funny I really
liked her I really made for TV yeah I
like her a lot I just like in person
there's so much vibe yeah yeah I love
seeing them at
okay magazine party they were so fun
okay the other one I really love - I
love Gina OCD her she wouldn't get along
I mean no she just walked right up to me
and we hit it off and we were talking
about kids and then and she was just a
delight like I love talking to her an
interesting one who was a little bit she
thick um well you know no one was super
[ __ ] I mean mm-hmm
I mean I feel like no I mean were busy
yeah yeah busy yeah and I I could have
taken it a different way but I knew they
were just busy because they wanted to
see people they actually Jenna right I
think you're wrong it was it was a lot
yeah I can't believe you were there
Denise Richards oh my gosh oh nice
only of her she was such a delight also
to me at any shower she came up to me -
and I was like starstruck and I didn't
want to be like the crazy fan like going
up to her at first and she came up to me
and oh my god I feel like she was really
nice
yeah she said she's a great house I love
her she's been such a delight which is a
great word that you use yeah a delight
from Sasi Smith did you always want to
get married and start a family at a
young age yes okay I don't know this is
so horrible but in my mind this is so
shallow but in my mind I was like I want
to get my babies out by the time I'm 30
okay first off I saw there was extreme
okay nowadays people sometimes don't
even start baby safar third right but in
my mind I had this whole image I want to
get my babies out - I'm 13 in it and I
literally I'm gonna tell Hilton do not
rush anything
take your time you know and for me I put
so much pressure on myself when I was
trying to have kids cuz I couldn't get
pregnant right away and I'm just like
don't do that just have fun and what
happens it happens yeah yeah you know
that's good advice
um this is some hat Ferger this is
actually a great question because you
guys talk a lot in the show about like
Dallas society and the implication I
hate that one right and I am so annoyed
when it first came up sees my first
season I was like why is that coming up
yeah I think I would have used it one
time mine accident and I really never
liked to use that word ever yeah you
like I just feel like when I when that
word comes up
just kind of like pretentious it's very
pretentious we can't like talk about the
relationship and then the role that the
show plays in quote-unquote Dallas
society like do people like the show
today downright well they
it is very frowned upon in Dallas I had
a feeling we are not supported ok very
front upon my girlfriend's who are very
into Dallas society I mean I have to be
honest they're very well-connected
I mean sometimes to get them to even
film with me they have to have like five
lawyers I got a conscience really you
know and it's like oh it's like a lunch
scene yeah but like they're tearing away
you know and I don't think they
understand yeah lots of things could
happen but like you're not gonna do that
no it's all I got
and like you're so interested or
something you were going to lunch
you know yeah I I don't know so they get
nervous but yeah it is not it's hard to
find places to film and sometimes people
like a lot of Russians that I go to on a
daily basis they're like our customers
here don't want to be on camera and so
we can't bail them like so that's a [ __ ]
like the summer house that films in
Montauk they struggle with that a lot
too like all the the local businesses
like signed a contract that they were
not gonna wear it was actually crazy
yeah but I've been so lucky my close
friends have always had my back they're
always watching with me on Wednesday and
they'll protect me wherever it is and I
really really I'm so thankful for that
and so that's great I'm not like a black
sheep Adele's right God we got like
seven thousand questions about your skin
care Oh
because even right now you're truly
glowing oh thanks what do you do okay
Hydra facials that's my favorite thing
have you guys had no but I've been
meaning to get one cuz someone suggested
it to me and I have a ok the perfect
candidate no hide your facial thing is
amazing it just sucks all the dirt out
okay so Hydra facial and then I
constantly am using TNS essential CRM
which is this serum that you that has
like growth like growth like collagen
it's like growth factors and it
basically like helps your cell turnover
I use that at night it's expensive
bottle but you guys I think it's like
275
but there's Braille and it lasts you
guys I think like seven months so it's
expensive but it's like amazing yes like
some things are worth investing in and
they also say cheese retin-a they said
retin-a has just been one of the things
for anti-aging
my skin gets really dry but I heard okay
if you put if it gets really dry the
time a key put lotion on first then the
retin-a and then you're getting a
lighter dose and then it's because that
helps with cell turnover - yeah and of
course I do Botox - yeah I was gonna ask
you I don't know if that's like a rude
question
yes who thus far had ever if I let her
let you guys I had wrinkles naturally
growing up like on my forehead just
because I have such strong facial
expressions and so I of course started
Botox yeah and I think I was like 2027
just cuz I didn't want them to get
deeper yeah and then once I got Botox
I'll say we started this year and it's
been a great decision forever yeah I'm
gonna Ness and it's not like I feel like
there's to be a stigma now it's just
like it's preventative it's medicinal
yeah maybe Zimmerman it for Vega now I
just need my crow's feet are getting
that you know I just have faced like I
can't have you done yeah that's what I
heard right here now that these muscles
don't move your eye muscles are working
harder so I know I don't want to start
doing it there though like then I can't
stop well I just started this year for
the first time and I little Botox like
right here because I smile you can see
it sometimes yeah so yeah when I smile
it's like a real smile it's crazy
but some certain lines like do really
and you don't want to be a person who
can't move their face like yeah right
certain lines like I'd like my dimples
like certain things in your base
actually do add character and you're not
ugly
yeah yeah yes but you want to look like
you're happy sometimes all the time the
moment of saratoga we have a picture
severs right right final question for
you if you could not ever wear pink
again what color would you wear oh my
gosh okay um you know mmm black me too
girl it's just classic you know I just
love black and it matches that mean well
so where was your bathing suit from this
episode it was your beautiful cuz you're
gonna die tache her shade yes you shop
at OJ okay
we were told we needed a bathing suit to
get messy and get rich and Harry said
bring a bathing suit you can
that you're not gonna cry oh well guess
what a lot of my bathing suits I would
cry if they got me yet and they're why
I'm moving out and I've got this
fabulous bathing suit I tried on like 20
when I put that one on you guys I think
it was twenty dollars by the way you
look amazing a neighbor model yes I
couldn't believe and like you're just
such a like a woman I know and I'm like
that's what I want to be when I grow up
so sweet I love you honestly I do think
I have to apologize I think I've
misjudged you when watching the first
two seasons we and Jackie actually was
really the Pioneer being like there's
more that meets yeah you know what was
the moment that turned for me was last
season when you were riding the bull I
just looked like so ethereal it was like
this juxtaposition and then was like
really the first time we were able to
see like you're like you're get down no
one asks you to ride to go before that's
true yes and you guys the only reason
why I probably didn't officially want to
ride the bull at first is because I'm
afraid of those bowl of course some
people get hurt a whiplash you know and
I'm the biggest baby when it comes to
anything adventure maybe - yeah thank
her because I'm like a jolly giant like
I'm so tall awkward and I don't have
good coordination so I feel like I'm
gonna fly up that thing and hurt myself
no and like you have kids yeah yeah with
a broken leg senseless like okay you
have you go on the bull and that's great
like what did that what did you get
reckless endangerment
nice right deal that yeah we talk on
that all the time well everyone should
follow cameron on instagram at camry
Wescott right make sure to do that
capture every week on the Dallas
housewives looking glamorous even if
it's from tarjay like I can't believe I
actually have a bus got target shops at
charge I thank you guys so much for
listening today the merch store is a lie
shadowy Joe's calm everything you need
check out our Instagram stories for a
bunch of pictures of all the products
and sizing we will see you on Monday
have a fabulous weekend bye
you